hello and welcome to this video playing
Piquet 15 is that the right one was a
problem that yeah it's PK 15 so I do
offer more no the classical yeah that I
have not yet studied so that could be
funny something like this is probably
known theory but don't ask me if this is
the right move order and what not he
plays very quickly though so it is
probably something no one or close to it
okay wants to trade my queen that's it's
understandable should I have prevented
this summer maybe
not sure should be three was actually
any good I can't threatening maybe g5
him okay um g5 I mean I understand that
I'm not playing for made any moment the
space is not bad to have I'm a bit
skeptical though about f4 here 925 they
will attack mine where center there so
let's not do that yeah generally
speaking endings on tend to be okay in
the Sicilian for black rather better for
black in most cases black asses to
Center pawns that control the center and
he's got the C file and minority attack
ideas this is often more real than than
the white ideas for TD five o'clock t7
third winning material
it's good that marking is on be one year
otherwise Alex he would play rook f7 I
could brew peace at Bishop g5 chick yeah
so I think I've taken b7 here probably
still attacking this so if he takes it
to takes f 3 takes these seven takes it
to which is just a full piece when it
works III rooks rook takes is seven
droop takes c3 and then take that hmm
that's an interesting tactic that I
should not allow so it just takes here
on takes on a three-headed should do the
trick it doesn't have a good term square
for the bishop like where detects
something I've got almost everything
went dark squares sorry one light
squares
they are probably let's go for doubling
on the 7th difficult home to prevent
yeah it's probably not very satisfied
with giving away the piece usually black
eyes I Lexi's it has a small victory of
the Queen sketch raided end I wasn't
aware of this this motif with Queen c-5m
I'm pretty certain that this is a
theoretical position or very close to
one so i went with g4 and now we had
this move yeah you know the engine isn't
actually so pessimistic about my
position I mean probably ever also
wasn't so pessimistic but it felt like
this should be very okay for him so here
when two day and night h5 I think came
into consideration here looking at those
squares I'm sure I probably would put a
plate 92 okay this one a three I think
hard to do without it in the long run 95
or fine I think here this must be okay
for him and now maybe not see for
something like that I thought it's
roughly equal and the engine agrees I
mean blackest is completely okay with
this position for sure as mentioned in
the Sicilian you are happy with an
ending normally don't think he's really
having something substantial him yeah
that was lucky and it just blunders a
piece basically yeah I think he probably
am it sometimes happens you kind of
don't consider a move like that where
the bishop takes the night because it
doesn't look like strategically good but
ok the two pieces are hanging one of
those cases where you can maybe find a
move of you see ok to hanging pieces is
there a way to attack them both and then
you kind of have this
illusion yeah okay that was a bit of a
bit of a small give it down thanks for
watching